Okay, good afternoon, everyone. First of all, I really appreciate your
presence during the lunch break, and especially, I think this is a very
interesting timing. But this is also a wonderful timing for us
because we will talk about metabolism.
So this section will
cover cancer metabolism and also how cancer and immune cells cross-talk
in a tumor microenvironment, which will change the way we control immune response
against cancer. And we have three speakers, and it's my pleasure to
introduce our first speaker who will cover the cancer metabolism part.
Gina will present
her new work, and she's coming from Memphis Cancer Center.
All right. Hello, everyone. I'll be telling you about metabolic
vulnerabilities within cancer cells.
Okay.
These are my disclosures.
So during the process of transformation through the formation of
pre-malignant lesions into the formation of locally invasive
cancers, through the process of metastasis and treatment
resistance, there are a variety of different metabolic vulnerabilities that
arise. Cancer cells must
resist stress, they must adapt to a nutrient-limiting condition, they must
adapt to new nutrient environments as they see distal organs.
And so there are a variety of different mechanisms by which cancer cells adapt
to these metabolic environments, one of which is the Nrf2 transcription
factor, which is a focus of my lab. So under normal basal conditions,
Nrf2 binds to a protein called Keap1, which recruits the Cull3 E3
ubiquitin ligase complex, which facilitates the ubiquitination and
degradation of Nrf2. However, when cells experience a stress like the
exposure to reactive oxygen species, this induces a conformational
change in Keap1. Nrf2 is no longer ubiquitinated, and it can
accumulate in cells, translocate into the nucleus, form a heterodimer with
small Maf proteins, and induce over 200 cytoprotective genes that
induce the detoxification of reactive oxygen species, and also metabolic
enzymes that help cells adapt to stress.
However, in cancer, this process is hijacked.
There are mutations in both Nrf2 and Keap1, which
disrupt the association between Keap1 and Nrf2 or
Cull3, so that the Nrf2-Keap1 system is,
Nrf2 is accumulated constitutively, and these target genes are now on all the time.
And this helps the cell evade the stress that is experienced during
oncogenic transformation and formation of tumors, and
also helps the cell adapt to a lot of different treatments such as radiation,
chemotherapy, and also in newer work, immunotherapy and targeted
therapy as well.
There are many metabolic alterations that arise when Nrf2 is
activated. Nrf2 promotes the acquisition of
amino acids like cysteine to help produce antioxidants that help the cell
evade stresses. And so one of the ways that Nrf2 does this is by
upregulating the cystine transporter xCT, in which cystine
is imported in exchange for the amino acid glutamate.
After cystine is imported, it has to be reduced.
And Nrf2 regulates the disulfide reductases GSR and thioredoxin
reductase, which in an NADPH-dependent manner, reduce cystine to
cysteine.
Nrf2 also promotes the synthesis of the antioxidant glutathione through the
transcriptional regulation of GCLC.
The acquisition of glutathione is really important for cells to
maintain a reducing environment.
Glutathione is used by both glutathione peroxidase 1 and glutathione
peroxidase 4 to detoxify hydrogen peroxide and lipid peroxides,
respectively. And this helps the cell evade the
accumulation of toxic levels of these metabolites, which can induce
the form of cell death known as ferroptosis.
Nrf2 also protects when cells are starved of cystine.
So when there is insufficient cystine present, there is
a failure to maintain adequate cysteine levels.
And so because there is insufficient cysteine, GCLC
cannot promote the formation of glutathione.
But we have found that Nrf2 still, through the regulation of GCLC, can protect
cells from oxidative stress, and that's because GCLC in a
non-canonical manner can ligate other amino acids to glutamate.
And the gamma-glutamyl amino acids that are produced themselves don't have
much of a function, but the removal of glutamate from the glutamate pool is
protective against ferroptosis because glutamate accumulation leads to the
formation of reactive oxygen species and lipid peroxides.
So by promoting the expression and activity of GCLC,
Nrf2 can promote ferroptosis protection in a
non-canonical way.
When glutathione is depleted within the cytosol, there is
a failure to detoxify reactive oxygen species and lipid peroxides.
But we find that while cysteine is depleted very rapidly
upon starvation, it has a half-life of about 20 minutes.
Glutathione will persist for hours, with a half-life of around six hours or so in
the cell.
So mitochondria will import what remaining glutathione is available,
and the mitochondria will break it down through an enzyme known as
CHAC1. This is an ATF4 target that is induced in response to
starvation. And a subset of CHAC1 will localize to the mitochondria,
where the cysteine liberated from glutathione will be used to sustain iron sulfur
cluster synthesis. So this keeps mitochondria functional under cystine
starvation. However, unlike the Nrf2 regulated GCLC
metabolic program, CHAC1 induction is actually
pro-ferroptotic. So there are metabolic outputs of the mitochondria that
actually are beneficial to the mitochondria but are detrimental to
overall cell health. So there are many metabolic adaptations that occur in response
to cysteine starvation, but not all of them are
beneficial.Most more
recently, in the last couple of weeks, work from Ioannis Sakaris's lab has found
that there is an extracellular enzyme, GGT1, that performs a similar
function to CHAC1. And GGT1 will break down glutathione
extracellularly as a source of cysteine.
So when cells are starved of cysteine, glutathione can play an important source of
cysteine,
where the either dipeptides produce cysteine glycine or
the cysteine that is liberated from them can be imported into cells and
provide an important source of cysteine.
So what their lab has found is that when cells are starved of cysteine,
they start to die after around 24 hours. These are breast cancer cells here.
But if they provide them now glutathione, the cells are perfectly happy and they'll
continue to survive and proliferate.
And this is GGT1 dependent because if he performs the same
experiment, but in the presence of a GGT inhibitor, GGSTOP, now the
cells start to die. And he has treated mice with this inhibitor
as well and found that it pretty potently impairs their tumor growth in
vivo. So glutathione has been a pretty underappreciated source of
cysteine to cancer cells.
But not everything Nrf2 does is promoting protection and stress
resistance. There are a lot of vulnerabilities associated with cysteine
metabolism. So as cells are importing cysteine, they're
exporting glutamate. And so for every molecule of cysteine that comes in, one
molecule of glutamate has to go out.
And so for Nrf2 active cells that are continually importing cysteine
to sustain glutathione synthesis, they become glutamate limited.
So the intracellular concentration of glutamate drops.
And so Nrf2 active cells become sensitized to inhibitors of
glutamine metabolism or glutamine breakdown.
So there's an interest in targeting this with inhibitors like CB-839, which
inhibits glutaminase, or DRP-104, which antagonizes
glutamine metabolism. And this is work from primarily Thalis
Papagiannakopoulos.
Once that cysteine comes in, it has to be reduced through, as I mentioned,
thyroxine reductase or glutathione reductase.
And the NADPH that's used for this process has to come from somewhere.
And work from Boyu Gan's lab has found that the pentose phosphate pathway is an
important source of the NADPH in the cytosol for cysteine reduction.
So Nrf2 active cells are sensitized to inhibitors of glucose
uptake. And when treated with glucose
uptake inhibitors, this antagonizes
their NADPH levels and leads to the accumulation of
cysteine. We have found that the accumulation of cysteine
within the cell can be toxic as well.
Cysteine stabilizes an enzyme called CDO1, which
catalyzes the irreversible metabolism of cysteine to taurine.
And so in non-small cell lung cancer cells, this not only produces
taurine, but some toxic intermediates downstream in the taurine synthesis
pathway, and also leads to the depletion of NADPH
as the non-small cell lung cancer cells are continually trying to replenish the
cysteine pool. So non-small cell lung cancer cells evade this
vulnerability by epigenetically silencing CDO1.
And finally, when
glucose uptake is inhibited and NADPH is depleted, the cysteine
that accumulates leads to formation of aberrant disulfide
bridges in the actin cytoskeleton, leading to a different form of cell death
called disulfidatosis. And this is recently described by Boyu Gan's
lab. So there's really a lot of ways that Nrf2 activation
confers different metabolic vulnerabilities.
But there's one new one. So this is work from Lucas O'Sullivan's lab that's brand
new, just came out, I think, two weeks ago.
And they found that cysteine, in addition to these other toxic outputs of
cysteine that have previously been described, also forms adducts within cells.
And so in addition to some reversible conjugates that can be
formed within cells like that with pyruvate, it can also form irreversible
adducts with some intermediates in the glycolytic pathway to form these
cysteine sugar adducts, which can be toxic.
So the accumulation of too much cysteine within
cells with Nrf2 activation can also be detrimental.
So there's really a fine balance between having too much cysteine and too little
cysteine within cells.
So a lot of the work that I've told you about has been performed in cell culture,
where we're giving cells really a lot of cysteine or starving them
completely. But in vivo, the situation is more complicated.
There may be nutrient gradients. Cells are very rarely completely starved or
given extreme excesses of nutrients.
So we're really interested in understanding what is the source of cysteine in vivo
and how is it used, and how does that depend on how much is available.
And so I told you a lot about xCT. This pathway is regulated by
Nrf2. But there are other ways to get cysteine, and one of these is the
transsulfuration pathway, in which methionine donates the
sulfur and serine donates the carbon backbone.
And this pathway is very active in the liver, but its
contribution to cysteine in other tissues and within tumors is
really not well understood.
Cysteine could technically be imported directly
through cysteine transporters. Their identity is not very well understood.
And in our cell culture media, cysteine is completely absent, and it's
also lacking in our blood as well. So how much cysteine is actually
available to tumor cells is pretty underappreciated.
And so we wanted to understand this in vivo.
So we use a variety of different genetically engineered mouse models.
And I'm just showing you two, I think that highlight the diversity
of the activity of this pathway. So first starting with the liver, we
used a hydrodynamic tail vein injection model to overexpress Myc and delete
p53
and compare liver tumors that form to a
normal healthy liver. And so we used carbon-13 labeled serine that we
infused into mice and then looked at labeling in cysteine.
So what we found was that normal liver had activation of this
pathway. And when we compared the tumors, we found that there
wasPretty similar labeling. There was slightly less in the liver tumors,
but all tumors had some detectable cysteine production.
And we could follow that into glutathione synthesis by looking at
gamma-glutamylcysteine. When we looked at the
lung, though, we found that the lung had no detectable labeling in cysteine from
serine, so no transsulfuration activity.
And when we looked at two different lung cancer models, one driven by a mutation in
KRAS and loss of p53, and then another similar model where we added in
a Nrf2 mutation, we found that lung tumors did not gain the
ability to make cysteine.
And not surprisingly, because they didn't make cysteine, there was no labeling
in the glutathione synthesis pathway.
So we would predict based on this data that lung tumors would likely be very
dependent on uptake of exogenous cystine,
whereas liver,
because they can make their own cysteine, maybe would be less dependent.
But we wanted to know how much cysteine is labeled from the circulation.
So we repeated this experiment and infused mice with labeled cystine.
And what we found was that when we did that, the normal
liver could also take up circulating cystine and label the cysteine pool,
and the liver tumors could as well.
Although again, we saw a slight decrease in the tumors suggesting there was maybe
contribution from an unlabeled cysteine source, maybe glutathione,
like Isaac reported, maybe something else.
And we could follow that into glutathione synthesis.
Whereas in the lung, we only saw labeling from cystine in the cysteine
pool with no real difference between lung and the two different lung tumor
models. But when we looked at glutathione labeling, that's where we really saw a
difference with a progressive increase when we went from lung to the lung
tumor model to the Nrf2 mutant lung tumor model, consistent with what we know about
Nrf2 promoting glutathione synthesis.
So from this, we would predict that if we blocked cystine uptake, this would be
very potent to a lung tumor model, maybe less potent to a
liver cancer model.
One caveat to our study, though, was that when we infused the mice with uniformly
labeled cystine, it formed mixed disulfides in the circulation.
So the cystine may be entering into the tumors or the
tissues as cysteine. We can't really distinguish from our methods.
So we spent a lot of time trying to target
cystine transport or the circulating cysteine pool,
and we had some technical issues with cystinase, which degrades
cystine and cysteine. It worked with a single dose, but with
sequential doses in immunocompetent mice, it lost activity.
We think there is potentially immune reaction to the enzyme.
So we went downstream, and we reasoned that if we targeted the disulfide
reductases, the tumors would not be able to reduce cystine to cysteine.
And because they naturally lacked this step here in transsulfuration
in our lung tumors, they would have no source of cysteine.
And so we did this. We knocked out both enzymes in a KRAS-driven lung
tumor model with and without a Nrf2 mutation.
And we were surprised to find that it only really had a moderate effect on tumor
number, also tumor grade. And we really
couldn't
understand why the tumors seemed okay.
They need cysteine, and there must be another way that they were getting the
cysteine.
And so sorry for the pixelation. Some of my images coming up lost
resolution in the
upload. We did this also in a more aggressive model.
More recently, we're still working on counting these tumors.
But if anything, it looks like macroscopically, they're bigger and maybe
nastier looking. So we think that this is, in this adenocarcinoma
model, is also, they seem to be somewhat insensitive to
loss of these disulfide reductases.
So we needed to reevaluate some of our assumptions about how this metabolic pathway
was working.
So nutrient availability impacts metabolic vulnerabilities, and
we do a lot of work in cell culture where we're
giving an excess of nutrients, and we also like to look at the
blood and think about that as physiological nutrient availability.
But work from Isaac Murra has taught us that what's locally available to tumor in
the interstitial fluid can be quite different from the circulation.
And so he's
characterized by metabolomics the nutrient
availability of interstitial fluid and found it can be quite limiting in
certain metabolites and have quite a lot of other ones.
So we
followed his example,
and we looked at both blood and interstitial fluid.
And so first we looked in the serum, and like what was previously reported,
we find that in our two different lung cancer models, there's really no cysteine
available. The redox state of the serum is very oxidizing.
And when we look at cystine, there's about 10 to 15 micromolar,
but it's all the cystine form, no cysteine.
And the glutathione redox state followed the same trend.
We found no reduced glutathione. All of the glutathione was in its
oxidized disulfide form. So totally consistent with what we
knew from the literature and our previous
experiments. Then we collected interstitial fluid from these
models and asked what about cysteine availability locally.
And again, sorry for the pixelation, but I think it's legible.
So when we compared serum to lung, then to lung tumors,
we found that normal healthy lung looked a lot like the serum.
So there was very little cysteine present.
It was all cystine, and the concentration looked pretty similar to the blood.
But when we looked at the lung tumors, we found that it was flipped.
So there was cysteine present locally in the tumors, and it was quite high,
about 40 micromolar, with very little cystine, only about two
micromolar. So thinking about transporter dependence,
they're likely not taking up cystine.
They're instead using a cysteine transporter.
And glutathione, the redox state, followed a similar trend.
There was quite a lot of reduced glutathione in the microenvironment, about one
millimolar, really high levels. And the oxidized glutathione was found
in both normal lung and the lung tumors.
So we think this is very much changing their transporter
dependence, their usage of cysteine, and the availability of
reduced glutathione maybe is keeping that cysteine in its reduced
form.So if we looked across a lot of
different metabolites that we found in the interstitial fluid at the concentrations
that they're present, there are a lot of amino acids, for example, that are
somewhat similar between interstitial fluid and our cell culture media, within
one to two times. But then there's a lot that are really different.
So for example, taurine is about 10 millimolar in interstitial
fluid and totally absent from our RPMI.
So,
we don't necessarily want to study metabolite availability in isolation.
We want to look at all of the interaction of all of these things together.
So we made a media that we call sTIF,
and we looked at the impact of that on cysteine/cystine
dependence. And so cells in this media, this yellow
color here, they grow very happily.
And then when we block the usage of cystine in either RPMI or our
media with erastin, we find that in RPMI,
cells start to die, these are H1299, after about
12 hours. But in our custom media, they grow very
happily, likely because there's very little cystine around, and they now
have access to cysteine.
And so there's a lot of metabolic implications in terms of vulnerabilities
for use of cystine directly.
So normally, when you're using cysteine, or sorry, use of cysteine
directly. Normally, when you're using cystine, you need to use one molecule of
glutamate for its import and a molecule of NADPH for its
reduction. So, not having to spend
these energetic substrates for cystine
metabolism means that they're now available for other things.
And so, we see that in our sTIF media, there's a pretty
dramatic accumulation of glutamate.
And when we look at sensitivity to CB-839, which has been
proposed for targeting Nrf2-active tumors, we see that in
RPMI, cells become very sensitive to it with an increasing
concentration, especially A549 cells, which are KEAP1 mutant.
But if we look in sTIF, cells really don't care.
Even at the highest concentration, some of these cell lines will proliferate like
nothing's there.
So we think that this is a tool to understand how the
nutrient microenvironment is impacting metabolic
vulnerabilities. And the next step really is to understand what are the
vulnerabilities in this media that we never would have uncovered in RPMI.
Because I think that in addition to the impact on cysteine metabolism,
there's probably some metabolic interactions between not just
the fact that it's cysteine and there's high glutathione, but there's other things
there that are going to impact on transporter dependence and
downstream factors. And so with
that,
I want to acknowledge everyone who did the work, especially Basman Froza,
who performed the newer work that I showed you, the unpublished work, and I'll
take your questions.
Hi. Great talk. I saw that in your media experiments, there wasn't complete cell
death. It seemed that it kind of trailed out at the end.
Did you do any experiments on those cells to see if they were maybe adapting in a
different way?
Sorry, if they were what?
Like maybe they had other metabolic adaptations to
kind of senesce, or what was kind of going on there?
Yeah. So I think that
the way that that graph
really shows you the cell number doesn't quite capture the overall death.
We also monitor with Cytoc Screen to count dead cell over time.
And that particular cell line does have pretty complete cell
death. But we do see with some other lines that they do
sort of adapt a little bit. So we haven't really characterized what happens to
those cell lines.
Cool. Thank you.
Thanks.
Really interesting talk. I was curious, so Thermo Fisher has a human plasma-like
media.
Mm-hmm.
Of similar changing the micronutrients to mimic human
plasma. And how does your sTIF compare to something like that?
Because it seems like you're almost going slightly the different direction where
you're adding metabolites and nutrients versus the
HPLM is a lot more like reduction. So have you compared the two?
So in some experiments we do. We've made a
serum-like media from our own
calculation. So HPLM,
I think some of those early medias, they don't capture the thiol
content because you need to derivatize the thiols to get good quantitative
analysis because they oxidize during extraction.
And so in some experiments, we do look at media formulated to look
like the plasma. But for these experiments, we're
looking more at the local
metabolite availability. And so for that, some metabolites are very, very high,
much higher than what you see in plasma, but some are very, very low.
So there is no cystine, for example.
We removed that, but we replaced it with cysteine.
So I think it really depends on the local microenvironment, whether you need to
add or subtract.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. That was a lovely talk, actually.
I just am curious because I'm from a very lung cancer background.
So I was wondering, because we all know that lung cancer, even
adenocarcinoma can be very heterogeneous.
So I was just wondering, what are your thoughts on the heterogeneity factor?
Because I've seen that you have mostly used KP models or
KRAS G12D and P53 models. Just wondering, what are your
thoughts on different other models like KRAS G12C
or even lung cancers that
have KEAP1 mutation. What are your thoughts on that?
Yeah. So that's a great question. So, in addition to heterogeneity
between cancer models, we're also interested in spatial heterogeneity because
the way that we collect interstitial fluid, we only get one or two microliters from
these models, but we have to combine tumors.
So I think it's much more complicated than that.
But I can speak to the
different cancer model heterogeneity.
So we haven't looked between KRAS G12C and D.
We just have those mice now that we're breeding, so we can do that
experiment. But we have compared KRAS P53-driven lung
cancer to KRAS P53-driven pancreatic cancer, and it looks quite
different. So we do see more cysteine
locally in the interstitial fluid than normal pancreas, but it's not
quite as high. It's only about 10 micromolar.
So we think that the microenvironment is very different in pancreas compared to
lung, so it's contributing to that fact, to the
availability. But it's a great question.
So we're trying to think, how can we look spatially at cysteine availability
at the single-cell resolution, and I think we need biosensors.
I think there's other ways, but we can't do that quantitatively with
metabolomics. Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, just quickly. Thank you for the nice presentation.
Your culture was 2D culture, right?
Sorry, can you say that again?
The culture is the 2D culture, right?
Yes.
Yeah. Did you try to make the 3D cultures?
The accessibility of nutrient can be different, and the
reality in the tumors is heterogeneous.
You have the cells from microenvironment, and also
the cancer cells itself. Other than that, the tumors,
the cancer cells themselves, they are heterogeneous above the steady
state level of their metabolism. Are you taking into account all these
factors?
So we have done a little bit with spheroids, but one of the challenges with making
these medias is that I think our normal cell culture media is formulated to have an
excess of nutrients because they're constantly being consumed.
And so with these sort of 2D culture systems, it's much easier to
change the media every single day.
Once you get into 3D, it's a lot harder to change the media constantly.
So we've been thinking about, with these more
complicated systems, how can we perfuse?
How can we keep the nutrient availability at a steady state?
Because some of these metabolites are quite low in the media, not necessarily
cysteine, but arginine, for example.
So the cells will quickly exhaust those sort of metabolites.
But we have done a little bit with spheroids.
Hey, Gina, that was a very thought-provoking talk.
So the established human cancer cell lines that you work with, they
were obviously made from a human being
established into tissue culture-
Mm-hmm
... and have been cultured for probably many years in full media.
Mm-hmm.
Just wondering, though, if you were to take your KRAS P53 lung
cancer model
and then derive cell lines from that, but do so in different
media conditions, I'm wondering how that would
influence metabolic dependencies.
Yep.
Because clearly the thing that you select for when you grow them in a defined
media
may be different from one, especially in a situation with P53
deficiency, since we know that can have quite profound effects on
metabolism. But it's really more of a thought experiment.
Just wondering if you've ever thought about doing this or have done it.
We started doing it. So it's a great question. So we had the same idea.
All I can tell you is that they seem to grow happily in the media out of the mouse,
but we haven't done very much phenotyping or RNA-seq or any sort
of experiments after the fact. But yes, we are thinking along the
same lines. So thank you for that, bringing that up.
Gina.
So there are two
questions from the online. So the first one is regarding to
whether you block the cysteine synthesis, the tumor
cell will reprogram to use other amino acid as a source to compensate
this blocking effect. And the second one is that do you confirm whether the cancer
cell, they will be able to produce, or other cell in the tumor microenvironment
will produce cysteine?
So for the first question, our lung cancer cells don't
make cysteine, so we haven't done any work blocking cysteine
synthesis because they naturally just don't do it.
We've done tracing in the cell lines too, and we see absolutely zero labeling
in cysteine. For the second, in terms of cells in the microenvironment, we've
started looking at that, looking at the ability of
macrophages that we isolate from the model, CAFs that we isolate from the model,
and their ability to secrete cysteine, and we see that macrophages do have a
contribution. And if we co-culture our lung cancer cells with macrophages, it will
rescue erastin treatment. So we think that they are at least one of
the contributing factors. We don't think they're a major contributor to the
glutathione, though, and we're still trying to figure out what's going on with
glutathione and where that's coming from.
So-
That's good
... thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay, so I'm this next speaker. I just forgot to introduce myself
in the beginning of the section. I'm the chair of the section and also speaker of
this section. I'm Ping-Chi Ho from Lausanne, Switzerland.
So today, I'll talk about
T cell behavior in the tumor microenvironment and how the metabolic process
happening in the tumor microenvironment will be able to affect T cell behavior.
So as I mentioned in the introduction of the section, we will cover
cancer, T cell, and also macrophage.
Okay, so
I would like to switch the gear a little bit.
So before I go through all the experimental detail, I want to let you know what is
the T cell differentiation happening in the tumor microenvironment.
So here which is very different from the viral infection or acute stimulation.
We know that in response to chronic antigen happening in the tumor
microenvironment, CD8 T cell, they will differentiate in a very different manner.
So they will start to have a stem-like property, and this is the population that
will sit there, and then do self-renew.
They can also respond to immune checkpoint blockade treatment.
They highly express several surface marker at the same time, the expression of
FOXO1, BACH2, and TCF1, those transcription factor
can control their stemness property.
Unfortunately, in response to chronic antigen exposure, those T cells
will start to lose this expression, and they start to express
BLIMP1, EPHB2, those factors which can control effector function,
even push the T cell into so-called terminal exhausted T cell condition.
And this will completely change the T cell quality.
At the same time, T cell fail to respond to PD-1 blockade treatments.
They also down-regulates the ability to proliferate, to produce cytokine.
And this represent one of the major problem for our cancer immunotherapy, because
our T cell with the best T cell receptor to recognize those
neoantigen expressed by cancer cells, they mainly go through this
process and become dysfunctional T cell.
So if we understand the process, we might be able to develop treatments to either
prevent the commitment of T cell exhaustion or restore the
functionality of those T cell.
So a few years ago, when I was a postdoc at Yale, I proposed
that in the tumor microenvironment when T cell infiltrate, they will start to fight
against cancer cells. However, T cell, when they proliferate, when they produce
cytokine, they need to use a lot of glucose and go through glycolysis pathway to
maintain their expansion like cancer cells.
But due to the metabolic restriction and also the high metabolic activity of cancer
cells, you can consider some of the tumor types you will see very low level of
glucose in a tumor interstitial fluid.
In this case, T cell will not be able to get sufficient glucose.
However, we also know that those T cells still can hang there.
They can still survive. So it raise a very important question.
This probably is a condition those T cell need to engage metabolic
adaptation. They will start to survive.So as everyone learned in the
biochemistry textbook, mitochondria is one of the major organelle
in our cells which can help the metabolic adaptation.
So if you don't have glucose, once you have mitochondria activity, you can start to
burn fats, you can start to use amino acid as a nutrient.
So at that time, we speculate maybe those CD8 T-cell in the tumor microenvironment,
they cannot get sufficient glucose, but they start to increase their mitochondria
activity to maintain their survival.
So we isolate CD8 T-cell from tumor-bearing mice, either from tumor
or spleen, and we perform electron microscopy analysis.
As you can see here, we indeed see increase of mitochondria content in those CD8
T-cell infiltrate into the tumor microenvironment.
However, my postdoc, Iru, did the analysis to check whether we can see the
mitochondrial DNA copy number increase. We didn't see that.
So this raise a very important question.
Most of the CD8 T-cell, they infiltrate into the tumor microenvironment.
They start to increase their mitochondria based upon the morphology.
But probably those mitochondria they have actually lose the integrity to
maintain mitochondrial DNA copy number, and which is very common for aging
cells.
So at that time, we proposed this idea, maybe this is a default setting.
When every single T-cell go into the tumor microenvironment, they will start to
encounter metabolic stress happening in the tumor microenvironment.
This lead to gradually increase of damaged mitochondria or depolarized mitochondria
stay in the cytoplasm of those T-cell.
They will not be able to remove them, and this can promote T-cell dysfunction.
At the same time, Craig Thompson and also Gregg DeGoeffe, they also report the
same thing. And these three paper published almost in a three-month period
to
reveal this
process. Unfortunately, none of the paper really disclosed
the underlying mechanism. So my other postdoc decide to work into the detail
to understand what happened, and we'll probably be able to
generate the therapeutic approach to prevent this process.
So that's come back what happened.
So we know that in a tumor microenvironment is glucose-deprived condition.
So for cells, they need to survive, they need to increase the mitochondria
activity, increase the mitochondrial biogenesis.
However, there's another metabolic stress happening in the tumor microenvironment,
which is hypoxia. So basically, those CD8 T-cell, they need to run oxidative
metabolism in low oxygen condition.
This can damage their mitochondria due to robust mitochondrial
ROS production. And normally this is fine because we can use
mitophagy to get rid of damaged mitochondria.
However, those T-cell in tumor, they also see very strong T-cell
receptor signal which can activate MTOR and block autophagy and
mitophagy. So in that case, they enter to a perfect storm.
In one end, they damage their mitochondria.
On the other hand, they cannot remove the damaged mitochondria.
And this is very dangerous because you still have those damaged mitochondria, you
still have those mitochondrial protein in a damaged organelle.
So we speculate those cells, in order to survive, when they accumulate
damaged mitochondria, they need to engage other homeostasis
pathway to dampen the mitochondria activity.
Otherwise, those damaged mitochondria will start to create different or
unwanted biochemical reaction, further damage the cells.
So we decide to take a look at what happens.
So basically, we isolated the CD8 T-cell in a tumor microenvironment based upon
their mitochondria staining. So we can use MitoTrack Green to stain the
mitochondria mass and MitoTrack Deep Red to stain the mitochondria membrane
potential. As you can see here, this population we call MDR, MDR low.
They contain more mitochondria, but most of the mitochondria are depolarized.
And this is the T-cell subset. They are dysfunction.
They have a lot of exhaustion phenotype.
And by comparing the RNA sequencing data between the functional
mitochondria-containing T-cell versus those T-cell accumulate damaged mitochondria,
we start to see a lot of metabolic process start to change.
Among those metabolic process, proteasome is the one which related to
homeostasis robustly increase in those T-cell accumulate
damaged mitochondria. And in the beginning, we don't really understand what
happened. What's the reason you can see that?
And we decide to take a look whether we can really see the mitochondrial protein
degradation. So Yingxi did a very interesting and very smart
design. So basically, we just fuse the mCherry reporter with a amino
acid sequence. This is a Dron sequence which can receive
polyubiquitylation. Once you have a polyubiquitylation, this entire mCherry
will be degraded, so you will lose the mCherry reporter.
So basically, we use this Dron system and tag with the signal peptide
to make this entire fusion reporter either tag into the cytoplasm
or into the mitochondria. So we can monitor whether the degradation can
happen in a specific location. By using this method, we
realize that those T-cell accumulate damaged mitochondria, if we
block their protein synthesis, you can see the stability of this
mCherry. Those low population tend to degrade mitochondria
reporter way more efficiently compared with the T-cell
that still have functional mitochondria.
But if you check their cytosolic Dron reporter, nothing happened.
They have a similar degradation kinetics.
So this result indicates that when those T-cell accumulate damaged
mitochondria in a tumor microenvironment, they cannot remove damaged mitochondria.
They start to degrade mitochondria protein.
They use this approach to prevent those damaged mitochondria keeping
doing wrong biochemical reaction.
So we also realize that this can happen in human, because once we generate human
T-cell, they become progenitor with a stemness property or terminal exhausted
T-cell. You can also appreciate that those terminal exhausted T-cell tend to
degrade mitochondria reporter way more efficient than their counterpart.
In cytosolic Dron, nothing change.
So with this information, we start to wonder, maybe that's true.
We see the RNA sequencing pattern, we see the protein degradation reporter system,
but we want to know what kind of protein those T-cell accumulate damaged
mitochondria indeed degrade. So we perform similar analysis.
We isolate those T-cell based upon their mitochondria activity, and then we treat
them with either control vehicle or cycloheximide to prevent new synthesis of
protein. And then we subject them to proteomic analysis to
identify which protein was selectively degraded by comparing the control
versus CHK treated one. So as you can see on the right-hand
side, those T-cell accumulate damaged mitochondria.
They degrade tons of protein in the mitochondria.It can be out of membrane, in the
membrane, complex one, complex five, you name it.
They tend to degrade mitochondrial protein, not only the reporter.
So we confirm this is true. They tend to degrade mitochondrial protein when they
cannot use mitophagy to remove damaged mitochondria.
And by using this method, we can also confirm in other type by using human
T cell, we also see the same thing. In a human T cell, if they have damaged
mitochondria accumulation, they also get rid of mitochondrial protein way more
efficiently.
And one thing we also noticed by analyzing what kind of protein get degraded, we
realized that a lot of protein, this T cell accumulate damaged
mitochondria can degrade. They are hemoprotein.
They are mitochondrial protein. They have the biochemical reaction
activity when they bind with heme.
So if this is true, when T cells start to degrade those protein,
you can see those heme become freely available because they will
be released in the cytoplasm. They will start to bind to other
protein in the wrong cellular compartment to regulate cellular behavior.
So we decide to use another approach to confirm what happened.
So basically, we need to have a method which allowed us to monitor
freely available heme. And this is very simple.
We just need to use HRP. Most people use in the Western blot.
HRP actually is a hemoprotein. So we just need to purchase the commercially
available HRP and treat the HRP with acetone to make this HRP
become apo HRP. And we can incubate the apo
HRP with the cell lysate derived from T cell with damaged
mitochondria or functional mitochondria. So we use three method.
The first method is that mouse T cell, we give them mitophagy inhibitor
plus oligomycin A and antimycin A.
This can promote the accumulation of damaged mitochondria.
And the second method is a tumor cell conditional medium plus TCR stimulation and
hypoxia to mimic a tumor microenvironment.
In both method, those T cell accumulate damaged mitochondria.
They start to increase freely available heme.
We call them regulatory heme.
And the other one is a human T cell. We give them NY-ESO TCR, and then
we pattern the stimulation to mimic what happened in the tumor microenvironment.
They also accumulate damaged mitochondria.
They also tend to increase freely available heme.
So overall, our data suggests that this is a common mechanism can happen in both
mouse and human T cell. So when they start to accumulate damaged
mitochondria, they would try to polyubiquitinate those
mitochondrial protein to ship them into the cytoplasm and then
degrade them through the proteasome activity.
And once those protein degraded, heme will become freely available.
But one thing we have to do, as many researchers need to do, is that we
have to have the positive and negative control in our assay.
So I told Yingxi, maybe we should try to have a positive assay or negative assay to
confirm this regulatory heme measurement
is holding true. It's real. We are not just monitor something else.
So the real control we should do is that we should block
proteasome activity to see whether we can see the reduction of the
measurement. So that's what she did.
So she treat the cells with MG132. As you can see, both
T cell with functional mitochondria or T cell with damaged mitochondria, once you
treat them with proteasome inhibitor, Avidin decrease.
Okay, so this means our measurement indeed is true.
But something is quite interesting because we start to realize
when you treat the cells with MG132, those T cell
accumulate damaged mitochondria, they are terminal exhausted T cell.
They express very low level of Bach2.
But once you treat the MG132, you start to see Bach2 increase.
And when she told me this data, I said, "That's normal because it prevents protein
degradation." So you block it, you should see protein increase.
And like many training like to do, you always want to argue with your
mentor. So she showed me this one, say, "You are wrong."
We see Blimp-1 start to decrease.
So those T cell, they are terminal exhausted T cell.
They express high level of Blimp-1.
But once we treat them with MG132, you basically bring them down
to lower level. So it looks like prevent this entire
proteasome activity to block mitochondria protein degradation process,
you'll be able to reverse the T cell exhaustion pattern, push
those terminal exhausted T cell regain the expression profile like
progenitor exhausted T cell. They have the stemness property.
And we also monitor PI3K/mTOR. We didn't see any difference.
So it
give us a very important hint. This entire degradation process probably is
very unique and important for T cell differentiation.
So we also try to understand whether this is really holding true in vivo.
So we decide to isolate CD8 T cell from the tumor microenvironment based upon
the surface marker most of immunologists like to use.
But I don't want to show you all the markers, just believe me, we can
identify those T cell with the stemness property from tumor
microenvironment, we call them TPAX, the intermediate and the terminal exhausted T
cell. And we isolate those cells, and here individual line is
individual mouse. So we can see that no matter which mouse we
use, we can always see this tendency.
The more exhaustion severity you see in a T cell, the more freely
available heme you can detect in the lysate, which indicates that these
things should go hand in hand. It can happen in vivo.
So we start to wonder, maybe this research suggests that this entire degradation
process is a determined process to drive the commitment
of T cell exhaustion.
And if that's the case, heme may be the player because heme, people always believe
then they are--
When they become freely available, they can regulate cellular behavior because it
start to bind to other protein in the wrong compartment.
So in order to confirm that, we need to have an assay which allowed us to
manipulate freely available heme level without perturbing the
mitochondria activity. And luckily, we can achieve that by treating
cells with Heme. This is a chemical analog which can
be taken up by cells, and they can convert Heme into heme in the
cytoplasm. So we just need to activate the T cell
and give them another activation in the presence of control
vehicle or Heme.So basically, we first confirmed
the more Heme we add in the cell culture,
the higher freely available Heme we can detect by our assay system.
So this provide us a very important entry point to
manipulate the regulatory Heme level in the cells.
So by using this method, we decide to check whether those T cell experience a lot
of freely available Heme, they will start to commit exhaustion or not.
So we basically monitor their proliferation, their stemness
markers, and also their cytokine producing ability.
As I mentioned to you, when T cell become terminal exhausted T cell, they
lose proliferation, they lose their cytokine production, they also change the
way they express PD-1 and also the stemness markers.
So we confirm this can happen in vitro, but we want to know whether this is indeed
true in vivo. So basically, we use a immunology trick.
We activate those T-cell in vitro in the presence of
control vehicle or 50 micromolar of Heme.
So those cells in a 50 micromolar of Heme, they experience a lot of Heme.
And we transfer those T-cell into naive mice.
One day later, we give them viral infection.
Since those T-cell we transfer can recognize this viral antigen, so we can
monitor how those T-cell expand, how those T-cells start to produce
cytokine. As you can see here,
those T-cell experience high level of Heme.
They don't proliferate as well as the control.
And they also maintain higher level of PD-1, look like
terminal exhausted T-cell. Importantly, they fail to
maintain their TCF1 expression, so they lose their stemness property.
They also fail to produce cytokine.
So basically, our research suggests that this degradation machinery can
trigger the exhaustion commitment.
So to show summaries like this, when T-cell, they come into the tumor
microenvironment, in the beginning, they are totally fine.
They can maintain their mitochondria activity.
However, they see the metabolic stress, the perfect storm I mentioned in the
beginning, they start to accumulate damaged mitochondria.
In order to survive, they cannot remove the damaged
mitochondria, but they start to degrade mitochondria protein
to ensure they can still stay there.
As a trade-off, this can lead to Heme become freely available and then promotes
T-cell exhaustion. So the question become very simple: How can Heme do this
job?
So we try many things, RNA-seq, single-cell RNA-seq.
None of them can tell us what happened, because most of them just tell you the
consequence. So it doesn't really tell you the mechanism.
So Ying-Hui was desperate at that time, and then she said, "Okay, let's try a
very stupid and very naive method.
Can we just go ask ChatGPT what kind of transforming
factors have been reported to control T-cell exhaustion?"
And then we overlap with known hemoprotein.
And this is just very naive one, because we believe Heme directly
target those transforming factors, control T-cell exhaustion.
And I think this is the first time I see the example of ChatGPT can work,
before we really do the experiment.
So we overlap these two things, and we only see one target overlap,
which is BACH2.
So the BACH2 should be highly expressed by progenitor-exhausted T-cell.
And it is a transcriptional repressor. It bind to DNA, suppress gene expression.
It can suppress BLIMP1 expression.
It has been shown in macrophage and B-cell.
When Heme become freely available, Heme can bind to BACH2.
It can lead to two change. The first one, BACH2 would lose the DNA binding
ability.
Second, BACH2 will be degraded. So it looks like when you have Heme
become freely available, you shut down BACH2, you degrade BACH2, and then BLIMP1
will start to be expressed because the suppressor is not there.
So this make a perfect sense for T-cell exhaustion.
So in order to confirm that, we decide to generate a mutant form of BACH2, it
doesn't bind to Heme. So this is a mutant form of BACH2.
We mutate a cysteine residue in BACH2.
We co-transfer the T-cell express wild type versus a mutant form of BACH2
into the tumor-bearing mice. As you can see here, in both tumor and also draining
lymph node, those T-cell express mutant form of BACH2.
Even though they accumulate damaged mitochondria, they don't listen to those Heme.
They still maintain very good level of progenitor.
Okay. And in the lymph node, you can see that they look like a stem cell.
So this give us a very
confident hint. We identify one of the underlying
mechanism why the accumulation of damaged mitochondria can control T-cell
dysfunction. So they use this entire process to ensure they can
survive. But as a trade-off, they
maintain the persistence, but they lose the flexibility and their
plasticity in terms of differentiation.
The reason is that those Heme will go through the chaperone called
PGRMC2, enter to the nucleus. In one end, this
can get rid of the BACH2, to completely shut down the BACH2 expression
and promote BLIMP1 expression to provide the T-cell exhaustion.
On the other hand, due to time, I will not be able to share with you the data, it
perturb the circadian clock regulation in T-cell.
So those T-cell fail to maintain their circadian flexibility.
They will not be able to adapt all the stress they encounter in the tumor
microenvironment. And this creates the trouble.
And you may wonder, so what? We identify this method, but how can we target
this process to make the T-cell do much better?
This was the original angle we want to understand the mechanism.
So luckily, we have the chance to analyze six patients that receive
CD19 CAR treatment. And in these six patients, three of them, they are
complete responder. Once you transfer CD19 CAR into the patient, you
see the response. They can control tumor.
And the other three, they don't have any chance to respond.
Even use the same number, they don't respond. The tumor just keep growing.
Some of them even die very fast.
And luckily, in this assay design, we perform single-cell
RNA sequencing before we infuse the CD19 CAR product into the
patient, and also eight days after transfusion,
20 days after infusion. So basically, we can monitor whether the cell number
in the blood can indicate you are responder or not.
But it doesn't mean anything, because we see here and there.
It looks like the cell number cannot explain whether they are responder or
non-responder. But when we check the single-cell RNA sequencing data,
we realize that before infusionWe can
separate the T cell.
They have the memory-like features.
They are the stem-like population.
We also can see the granzyme B positive population.
They are the terminal exhausted T cell CD19 CAR version.
In both population, if you see
this population, those population with a stemness property, they express
lower gene expression pattern associated with proteasome activity.
And even within the same population,
patient, they are responder, their gene expression level can
be further lower compared with their counterparts in the
relapse group. So this result suggests that actually the quality of
those T cell has been determined whether they can engage this proteasome activity
or not. But this is only six patient.
We have some concern to make the big conclusion based upon this data.
So we decide to analyze the other two cohort from Carl June's paper.
In this cohort contain almost 100 patients, we see the same
thing.
First of all, you can see the right-hand side.
In the responder in Carl June's data cohort, we see that they have a lower
proteasome activity, gene expression score compared with those patient
that don't respond. In the other very big cohorts, around 90 patients,
you can have the patient respond immediately, or the patient respond
initially, but they start to relapse in one year.
Or those patient, they never, ever respond from the beginning.
You also see a very clear tendency, the response
negatively associated with their proteasome gene
expression score. So based on this information, we start to believe
we should target the proteasome activity to make our T cell differentiate in a
way they have the chance to maintain their stemness, to maintain their
ability to proliferate, produce cytokine, even can respond to PD-1 blockade
treatment. And luckily, this kind of drug is available
clinically. There's a proteasome inhibitor called bortezomib.
So we decide to use this inhibitor to see whether we can change the CD19 CAR
we generate in vitro. So we decide to use a human T cell as
a entry point. So here each line is one human
donor. So we produce their CD19 CAR in the
presence of a control vehicle or in the presence of this proteasome inhibitor.
Once we generate the CD19 CAR, we
incubate the CD19 CAR with the target cell repetitively.
In this case, they see the antigen over and over
again. Those CD19 CAR start to express PD-1, Ten-3,
CD39, which are terminal exhausted T cell.
But the CD19 CAR we produce in the presence of this proteasome inhibitor,
they have a better ability to limit the expression level.
They also express lower level, and if you use single-cell RNA sequencing, you can
also see that those T cell produced in the presence of
proteasome inhibitor, they maintain high proliferation signature, higher
ability to produce cytokine, cytolytic activity.
They can also produce more interferon gamma.
And we also use the humanized mouse model to confirm they indeed can control tumor
more efficiently compared with their counterpart derived in a control
treatment.
So overall, I would like to use this idea to tell you that first, we have a chance
to identify one of the underlying mechanism which can
link how the damaged mitochondria control T cell differentiation.
By learning from this process, we also realize we can target few things.
We can target either the PGRMC2 to prevent those heme
enter to the nucleus, or we can mildly target the
proteasome activity to change the process of this exhaustion to make the T
cell have a chance to hang in there and maintain their plasticity
to differentiate.
So overall, I would like to thank people in my lab, especially my super talented
postdoc and all the collaborators, because this is a very difficult project.
We need to cover both mouse, human, and also biochemical reaction, and also have a
chance to analyze the CD19 CAR. So it's impossible to do everything
by ourself, but it's very great to have the chance to work internationally to
conduct this research and also the funding resource.
I will be happy to answer your questions.
Really exciting data. I was curious, so you show that the mitochondrial
dysfunction was in complex, what was it?
Two and four of the electron transport chain.
Is this purely related to OXPHOS
ETP generating ATP, electron transport chain generating-- So if you come
in with rotenone, antimycin A to block electron transport chain, do you still
get this dysfunctional mito heme phenotype?
Or is it like if you block TCA cycle and pyruvate uptake, is it going
to get similar data?
We didn't do that. First of all, I have to say the proteomic data, we can only see
those because we cannot discover every single protein.
So the depths of the proteasome analysis, proteomic analysis is
around 6,000 protein in a quantitative way.
So we still have a lot of protein. We know they can be expressed, but we cannot
detect them. So that's why we don't see all of the component. Okay.
And target individual one to see which one is more important.
I don't know. We didn't do that, but I think the accumulation of damaged
mitochondria, they will not be able to remove the damaged mitochondria through
mitophagy is more important because they will just start to degrade everything.
And whether the selectivity will toll to complex one,
complex two, or complex three, I don't know.
At least we cannot make a conclusion right now based upon the depths of the
proteomic we did.
All right. Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. I'm just wondering that this
increased accumulation of mitochondria that you have observed in the
exhausted T cells,
has got something to do with the nanotubes, because there are some findings that
tumor cells steal the mitochondria
from the normal cells to the nanotubes from the Lin Jiang and Sweta Sengupta's
group.
So do you think this can be contributed also to that?
I would say it's very difficult to make the conclusion based upon the data we have
right now, because first of all, we know this can happen.
The nanotube can form, right? There is also the extracellular
vesicle delivery method can lead to this exchange.
But we
don't have a very good tool to distinguish what kind of
mitochondria they deliver, whether the mitochondria is the functional one or
the defect one. And you also need to be careful because most of the conclusion
people did in those experiments, they basically based upon mitochondria die.
And I think the best one is another nature paper.
They actually checked the SMP on the mitochondrial DNA.
That probably is the best method to confirm what kind of mitochondria is delivered.
So
I think this is possible, but we just don't have sufficient tool to
distinguish whether this is true and
whether tumor cells, they actually steal
the good mitochondria from T cell and put the bad one into the T cell.
I think we need more method to work on that.
And we actually wrote a new review for Immunity.
We cover this topic and discuss what kind of tool we should have in
order to address this issue, and hopefully it will be out in two months.
Sounds good. Thank you.
Really great talk. Yeah. I wonder whether you were able to
measure the heme level actually increase in the nucleus.
There are
nucleus specific reporter for heme.
We didn't do that. We plan to do that because at that time we submit a paper, we
think the reviewer ask, and we actually purchased those reporter.
But there's an issue because every single reporter for those
metabolites,
it depends on the dynamics of the measurement.
And that reporter we acquired, the dynamic is not that
good. So this is one particular problem.
So we also try to isolate a nucleus and see whether we can do the
same thing. But it's quite difficult because the more biochemical reaction
you perform, you will also introduce some issues because the chaperone
actually will become... If the nuclear membrane become partially permeable, you
will see the heme actually enter in a different way.
So that's why we didn't perform the solid experiment to confirm that.
But based upon the Bach2 degradation, I think this happened.
We just don't know how high the level is in the
nucleus.
Okay, thanks.
Do you think that heme influences also the early
TCR response through metabolic changes?
Yes or no. It depends on how you do the experiment, because if you add
heme into the normal culture,
the entire TCA cycle activity will increase, mitochondria activity also
increase. And the mitochondria activity will be able to control the
TCR activity in terms of the TCR
strength and also the duration, because it will control the immunologic synapse
stability. So I would say yes, it should be the case, but in
vivo, in a chronic antigen exposure condition or in a condition T cell cannot
get rid of mitochondria, this will be interesting angle to take a look.
And so far, we don't know the answer yet.
Thank you.
Okay, so thank you very much. So we will go for the last speaker.
So the last speaker is Stanley Huang from Ohio State University, and then he
would cover
immunometabolism in myeloid cells.
Thank you. So
today I'm talking about tumor-associated macrophages in my lab.
So another disclosure.
So we know that tumor mutations always associate with the response
to the anti-PD-1, PD-L1, but only about
10 to 30% of patient responds to anti-PD-L1 and
PD-1.
And one of the major roadblocks of these
less response is due to immunosuppressive tumor
microenvironment and then tumor-associated macrophages.
So
tumor-associated macrophage become a very obvious target.
So when you're looking at this published data, looking at this array of
the solid tumor,
you can see there's about 30 to 50% of infiltrated immune
cells are monocytic macrophages.
So it tell us it could be a obvious
strategy to manipulate this population to dampen the immunosuppressive
environment to enhance anti-tumor immunity.
So there's couple approaches or strategy has been proposed, have been
used in the field, and then try to
target myeloid cell population in a tumor microenvironment.
And then my lab is particularly interesting in three
aspect. One is the targeting the receptor ligand interactions,
and then also the epigenetic modification in macrophages.
And also a major direction of my lab is metabolism.
We try to understand how this metabolism can
dictate macrophages immunity, and how this surface
receptor or downstream epigenetic modifier link to metabolism
to further enhance immunosuppressive macrophages function.
So we know that the tumor microenvironment is very
different.
It's a complex environment, and then metabolism is very
hard for T cell to survive, like glucose metabolism, amino
metabolism, they are all deprived and compete out
from T cells and dampen the T cell immunity.
Also hypoxic environment that will also inhibit T cell
migration and T cell effector function, and also lots of lipid
accumulation in tumor microenvironments.
And these are all detrimental for T cell anti-tumor immunity.
However, these scenarios seem to be beneficial
for tumor-associated macrophages.
They seem
happy living in this environment.
So
our lab is trying to understand the interaction between tumor
microenvironment and tumor-associated macrophages, and in addition to these
known factors, how thatThose influence macrophages
development, become immunosuppressive population.
And then how can we make these traitors become
defenders? So we try to manipulate metabolism, make these traitors
become defenders to inhibit tumor progression and enhance
antitumor immunity.
So as Pinchi mentioned previously, showing that
mitochondrial function is dysregulated in T cell, and then it has
been shown in different groups showing that T cell have dysregulated
mitochondrial function. They cannot support T cell effector function to do the
antitumor immunity. So what happened to
tumor-associated macrophages? So I always call them, they survive well,
they're doing well in this harsh tumor microenvironment. So what happened to them?
So my lab previously showing that the tumor microenvironment
can induce tumor-associated macrophages ER stress
response. One particular stress response is PERK, and this
PERK activation is increased by this tumor microenvironment.
So
PERK is increased, and they promote downstream serine
metabolism control, this transcription factor ATF4 that
promotes serine synthesis, that promotes tumor-associated macrophage
survival, proliferation, and expansion.
And when we
conditionally delete this PERK
protein in macrophages, you can see this tumor progression is strongly reduced.
And then we further
prove that downstream serine synthesis protein called
PSAT1 is controlled by this pathway.
And then when we conditionally delete PSAT1 in tumor-associated macrophages,
we can see the tumor progression is decreased.
So this data strongly suggests that tumor environment can
really manipulate tumor-associated macrophage metabolism and make them
metabolism different from T cell, and then these promote their
immunosuppressive function.
So
what's next? So we
try to address what happened to mitochondrial function in tumor-associated
macrophages. We know T cell mitochondrial function is impaired, so what happened
to macrophages? So how they can survive well, can doing
well, then they proliferate well to block the antitumor immunity.
So one of my postdoc, Haoxing Zhao, try to answer these
questions. So first of all, we did a kind of public available
data set analysis. We're looking at the human lung carcinoma.
You can see this compared to tumor-associated macrophages versus
non-tumor macrophages. This tumor-associated macrophage enrich with
mitochondrial function
compared to non-tumor-associated macrophages.
Similarly, in the liver cancer, tumor-associated macrophage also have
increased oxidative phosphorylation mitochondrial function compared to
non-tumor-associated macrophages.
So the data strongly suggests tumor-associated macrophage have increased
mitochondrial expression activity that will promote them
or sustain their immune function in the tumor microenvironment.
So long story short, we identify a molecular chaperone in
mitochondria in tumor-associated macrophage called TREM1.
So what is TREM1? TREM1 is a tumor necrosis factor receptor-associated
protein one, and this is a mitochondrial chaperone of the
Hsp90 family, and it's a key modulator of
mitochondrial respiration. And then expression of TREM1 is mainly
present in the inner membrane of the mitochondria, and it's linked to
mitochondrial function such as oxidative phosphorylation, redox
control, protein folding, dynamics, and mitophagy.
And importantly, it has been suggested to
control the complex II and complex IV in tumor cells
that will promote the Warburg effect.
So this protein suppress complex II and complex IV promote
Warburg effect in tumor cells. However, the role of this protein in
immune cells are known, so that trigger our curiosity to see
whether this protein, this chaperone, play a role in macrophages.
So we
did a analysis looking bone marrow-derived macrophages, these proteins
showing in the mitochondria, not in the cytosol, you can see here.
And then we transplant melanoma Y111.7 to mouse.
You can see
this versus-- We isolate spleen macrophages and tumor-associated macrophages.
As you can see here, this tumor-associated macrophage has strongly
reduction of TREM1 expression level from ninety-one percent to about
thirty percent. And it suggests this TREM1 is strongly
suppressed in tumor-associated macrophages.
So we want to understand what the role of this TREM1.
So we stratify this protein expression level to TREM1
positive and TREM1 negative. So when tumor-associated macrophage have
TREM1 negative, they have strong immunosuppressive function, like cold,
like high CD206, high Arg1. But when you
have retained TREM1 expression level, they are more
antitumor immunity, CD86, MHC class II high.
So
we also collaborate with Pinchi's lab showing that the colon cancer patient
show the same thing. If you have
TREM1 negative tumor-associated macrophages, you will have
high immunosuppressive marker CD163.
And obviously, the TREM1 high, you will
have more antitumor immunity, like CD86.
So these data strongly suggest tumor-associated macrophage with
low TREM1 by tumor microenvironment manipulation, they will
have strong immunosuppressed function.
So we want to understand the role of this protein in macrophages.
We generate condition knockout. You can see the
phenotype com-- is very comparable.
We also isolate bone marrow-derived macrophage, culture this macrophage
with a tumor condition media with wild-type knockout.
And long story short, we see this knockout, TREM1 macrophage has
strongly induction of the immunosuppressive signaling pathway
in theAnd two phenotype arginase 1.
And then they are all associated with angiogenesis,
macrophage differentiation, also mitochondrial
function. So this data suggests that tumor
microenvironment suppress TREM1 in macrophages, make them become traitors,
have more immunosuppressive property.
So we are working metabolism. We want to know what happened to this knockout bone
marrow macrophages. Well, when we use the Seahorse, you can see the TREM1
wild type with a naive RPMI, can see the metabolism is low.
But when you culture the wild type with TCM, tumor conditional media, the
mitochondrial function increase.
But when you further delete TREM1 in macrophages, this
mitochondrial function become hyper.
So it suggests that TREM1 is strongly associated with the
mitochondrial activity.
So then we want to understand when we delete TREM1, what happened to
mitochondrial function in tumor-associated macrophages.
As you can see here, you appreciate that when you knock out TREM1, the
mitochondrial mass is increased,
and then mitochondrial complex activity such as complex two in the in vitro with
the condition media, the knockout had more complex two activity.
So a little blurry. Sorry about that.
And also we sort tumor-associated macrophages from knockout mice.
You can see this knockout TREM1
condition macrophages have higher complex two activity.
And then this also lead to more Alpha-KG production important for
TCA cycle. And then upstream glutamine consumption is also increased
by this TREM1 deficiency. So this data strongly suggests
that the tumor
microenvironment can suppress TREM1 expression level in tumor-associated
macrophages that will accelerate the metabolism of mitochondria.
They will use glutamine from environment more efficient to
generate Alpha-KG to shuffle into TCA cycle.
So we always want to know how about in vivo.
So we further generate condition knockout cross the
floxed mice with the LsmCII. As you can see here, the wild type
mice have a robust melanoma progression.
But when you delete the TREM1 in myeloid cell, the tumor become
bigger. They become more hyper immunosuppressive.
We can see quantification here. Tumor size is bigger from the condition knockout.
And then you can see the infiltrated tumor-associated macrophage numbers
is strongly induced. And then the immunosuppressive properties, CD206,
arginase 1 is also increased. In contrast,
this knockout have lower anti-tumor immunity, lower CD86,
lower MHC class 2. And this lead to
different numbers of infiltrated T cells.
So knockout have lower T0 numbers, lower gamma positive
CD4 and CD8. And these knockout have
shorter the survival rate. So this data strongly suggest
TREM1 is essential-- I mean, reduction of TREM1 is essential to
support immunosuppressive function through the mitochondrial
function that promotes tumor-associated macrophage to survive,
growing better in the tumor microenvironment.
And I can see this,
we also sort the macrophage from tumor microenvironment
and co-culture with CDA T cell. Wild
type macrophage with CDA, the immunosuppressive-- sorry.
The gamma production and granzyme production is strongly reduced compared to
no macrophages. But when you with a knockout tumor-associated macrophages,
the capacity or induction of gamma production granzyme also
reduced. And then this knockout macrophage with the CDA,
they further reduce the proliferation rate of the
CDA T cell. So again, this
TREM1 deficiency tumor-associated macrophages exhibited greater
capacity to dampen CDA T cell to kill tumor.
So we want to know what is the molecular mechanism.
So long story short, we know the nutrient
sensor is AMPK. So AMPK is basically is a cellular
energy sensor for ATP, ADP, and AMP.
And the AMPK had been implicated regulate mitochondrial biogenesis,
and it has been shown that regulate macrophage immunopolarization function during
the tissue regeneration. However, the role in
tumor microenvironment is not clear.
So we measure the AMPK activity versus compare
tumor-associated macrophage versus spleen can see AMPK activation is increased.
Excuse me.
Furthermore, the in vitro
tumor conditional media showing the same thing.
AMPK induction is increased in the tumor conditional media in the
tumor-associated macrophages.
So we want to know whether AMPK link to TREM1 expression level.
So we generate AMPK hairpin knockdown.
So as well with the condition media, the TREM1
is reduced. But when you knock out AMPK, knock down
AMPK, the TREM1 expression level come back.
You can see AMPK division is decreased, showing that AMPK seem to link to
TREM1 expression level.
Also, the AMPK deficiency suppress mitochondrial function,
complex activity, Alpha-KG production because it is no
longer suppress TREM1.
AMPK deficiency also impair the immunosuppressive function,
lower CD206 and arginase 1. So this data strongly suggests
AMPK activation is linked to TREM1 expression level.
When you knock out AMPK, TREM1 come back, the mitochondrial function reduced.
And then we also want to know what control AMPK
inside. So it's known that TIM4 is
linked to AMPK activation, influencing inflammation in the macrophages during the
non-alcoholic fatty acid liver disease.
And this TIM4-mediated ferroptosis, apoptotic cell
occurrence in the two microenvironments.
We know the tumor microenvironment, tumor-associated macrophages can use TIM4
to scavenge the apoptotic cells to enhance immunosuppressive function.
However, the molecular mechanism is not really clearAnd then it's
known that TIM-4 can reprogram lipid metabolism in macrophages during
viral infection. And TIM-4-positive
tumor-associated macrophages impair CD8 T cell immunity has been published
a couple years ago, but molecular mechanism is not really clear.
So we want to know how TIM-4 control this immunosuppressive
macrophages. So simple experiment we did, we also
take the tumor-associated macrophages from
tumor site and then versus spleen macrophages.
As you can see here in this melanoma, these tumor-associated macrophages have
high TIM-4 expression level.
Then we want to know what happen if we
deplete or knock out TIM-4
regardless of metabolism. So I can see here in naive macrophages
with the
tumor microenvironment, the mitochondrial function is increased.
But when we knock out TIM-4, this mitochondrial function is strongly
reduced. So this suggests TIM-4 is linked to
mitochondrial function, maybe control TREV1 expression level.
So long story short, we also use the TIM-4 wild type knockout mice.
You can see here TREV1 in the tumor condition, the TREV1 expression
level decrease, MBK increase, activation increase.
But when we knock out TIM-4, TREV1 expression
level come back at MBK expression level decrease.
And it shows same thing, TIM-4 monoclonal antibody shows same thing.
MBK activation decrease by TIM-4 monoclonal antibody
blockade. And then we have seen this blockade
increase the TREV1 expression level.
And then we also did a data analysis looking at the
ovarian cancer tumor-associated macrophages.
When you have TIM-4 negative macrophages, the TREV1
expression level is increased, showing the same thing here from our initial
data.
So when we block TIM-4 by monoclonal antibody
or knockout, this immunosuppressive function is strongly reduced by
knockout. A monoclonal antibody also reduce
the CD46 expression level.
So the regulatory mechanisms like
tumor microenvironment increase the TIM-4 expression level, bind to the epithelial
cells PS, that will further enhance MBK activation.
And this activation further suppress TREV1 expression level
to increase the mitochondrial activity
through getting more glutamine metabolism, generate more alpha-KG shuffle
into a TCA cycle.
And then
we also want to understand how these metabolites that influence
the gene control, gene expression level in tumor-associated
macrophages. So we know alpha-KG is a cofactor
for
epigenetic modifier called GMG3, working under histone
demethylation. And it has been reported this histone demethylation is
important for M2 gene expression level in the asthma
model or helminth infection. But the molecular mechanism is not really
clear in the tumor-associated macrophages.
So simple experiment we did, we used a TIM-4
monoclonal antibody to validate this GMG3
activity through this alpha-KG production.
So in the tumor condition media, this histone
demethylation, H3K27me3 is decreased.
But when you block the upstream TIM-4, this methylation is
increased-- I mean, this demethylation is decreased.
That will further affect the
M2 gene expression level in tumor-associated macrophages.
So showing here
DNA demethylation-- histone demethylation is important
for promoting tumor M2-associated genes expression level.
And then we try to understand if we generate condition knockout
or use the select inhibitor, what happen to these tumor-associated macrophages.
So long story short, we generate the GMG3 condition knockout in the
myeloid cell compartment. You can see here when you delete GMG3,
this tumor progression for the melanoma is strongly reduced,
tumor size is reduced.
And in the GMG3 condition knockout, this tumor-associated
macrophage numbers is strongly decreased.
Immunosuppressive capacity, IL-206, Arg1 is
also strongly reduced by this condition knockout.
And this lead to make this tumor-associated
macrophage more CD86 positive, MHC class II positive, and
further lead to more, fortunately, T cell, TL numbers
increase, more CD4, CD gamma production,
TL in this tumor microenvironment.
And of course, this scenario will lead to prolong the survival rate
of the tumor-bearing mice. When we delete GMG3 in
tumor-associated macrophages, you will have strong anti-tumor immunity and
make these mice survive better.
So we always want to know what is the approach to target to
enhance the immunotherapy. So because we need to bring
the TREV1 back, so we cannot directly target TREV1, so we need to
target upstream or downstream. So we selectively use the monoclonal
antibody for blocking TIM-4 activity and also
use the select inhibitor of GMG3, GSKJ4, to see what
happen to the tumor progression. So can see here, can appreciate the
monotherapy is strongly reduce the tumor burden, tumor
progression. When you combine TIM-4 and
GMG3 inhibitors further reduce the tumor progression, the tumor size
is strongly reduced.
And this lead to the scenario that the combination
treatment make numbers of tumor-associated macrophage decrease, and then
immunosuppressive marker 206 decrease.
And this combination treatment making more T cell coming into
a tumor site, more numbers of TL, more percentage of
gamma positive CD4 and CD8. So that will make
tumor shrink and tumor size smallerAnd
this combination treatment is beneficial
for prolonging the survival rate of tumor-bearing mice compared to
monotherapy or untreated tumor-bearing mice.
So this data strongly suggests
perturbing surface receptor or tumor-associated macrophages.
TM4 will target in downstream epigenetic modifier,
JME3, can make mitochondrial function
different, lower, then make suppressive
capacity decrease. So this treatment definitely
brings back the TRE1 positive tumor-associated macrophages.
So in combination treatment, TRE1 comes back.
TRE1 comes back means this TRE1 can suppress
electron transport activity, decrease mitochondrial activity.
So in summary, we found that the tumor microenvironment
can really manipulate stress response in the tumor-associated
macrophages, and then through the ER stress protein, and we perturb
the ER stress protein, we can dampen this immunosuppressive
property. And furthermore, when we're
perturbing or targeting tumor
macrophages' mitochondrial function that increase the TRE1
activity, we will decrease the capacity of immunosuppressive
function. That will decrease the immunosuppressive environment,
increase the antitumor immunity.
And this metabolism also associated with epigenetic
modification through the alpha KG combined with the
JME3, and this will increase the gene expression level.
So this tells us manipulating
surface marker or metabolism or
epigenetic modification is an approach or
strategy that can enhance antitumor immunity through damping the
immunosuppressive capacity of tumor-associated macrophages.
So with that,
I would like to thank my lab and also all the collaborators around the world, and
then especially the PINCH who help, and then
the first project by
ER stress project by Lydia Rains, a PhD
student, now is a postdoc at Harvard, and a postdoc working on the
trap
for the
story. And then all thanks all the funding agency.
Without this, I can't go this far. Thank you.
Great talk.
Brad Reinfeld from MSK.
I guess with the AMPK activation, I wouldn't necessarily
expect the positive slope
on the
oxidative by glycolysis. What's happening to phospho S6
in mTOR activation
in the setting of the trap alterations?
So we did not do the phospho SK, that part.
We do not do that, so we don't know. But in the
other
part,
yeah, I don't
know that. Yeah. Sorry about that.
No problem.
Fascinating data. Yeah. I
was just wondering that a lot of tumors are addicted to
glutamine, and these macrophages are also using glutamine.
So, have you seen whether spatially these
macrophage
belong to the border of tumor where they have more access to
glutamine, these trap low macrophages?
You mean the glutamine level?
Yeah. I'm just wondering because there is a tumor also
utilize glutamine.
So
you mean, T cell have been deprived of glutamine from
the tumor microenvironment for sure, and then I think using this strategy,
tumor-associated macrophages can use glutamine more efficient, even the
level in the environment is very low, but they can use that more efficient.
That will shuffle into the mitochondrial function,
generating more alpha KG.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It's been very difficult to target macrophages for
therapeutic gain.
I mean, I noticed you didn't have anti-CD47 in your slide there, which is
touted as the most exciting recent macrophage
checkpoint. But I was just wondering from the work you're doing, which would you
say is your top target in terms of
re-educating the macrophage for patient benefit?
Because I haven't seen anything yet.
That is a great question, also a million-dollar question. So yeah.
So we try our best to
find the vulnerability of the tumor-associated macrophages.
So,
CD47 can work, but in the clinical trial, not really kind of working.
Also, anti-CSF1 receptor blockade, not really
benefit for the anti-tumor immunity.
So I think
from the mouse work, it seemed to work, but in the clinical trial, it doesn't
work. It's due to many, many reasons.
And then when you target one protein or one receptor, that will
compensate something. Something will compensate
the pathway. So
to be honest with you, I really don't know what's going on right now.
So in our hand, we try to understand what are
potential target we can do, and we working on the mitochondrial
function and also epigenetic modification, try to see whether
this
targeting combined with immunotherapy like NPD1, we can
benefit in the future. And then
using the human data as a surrogate to see what we
can do in the future. But I don't have direct answer
to answer your questions.
I may have missed this, but just as a follow-on, are you looking at the quantity
as well as the quality of these macrophages in the tumors in response
to targeting the metabolism?
So now we're using different strategies.
So we look in the numbers and also property.
So on quality and quantity, yeah, both.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Just a quick question,
did you see changes in uptake of tumor cells when you block
TIM-4? And did you maybe compare that to MERTK?
Yes, we did the data for-- I do experiment for
that, so we used the PS and also aptose cell to see that when we
block TIM-4, we can see the uptake of the PS or
aptose tumor cell decrease, and then the
suppressive function also changed.
And do you think maybe MERTK blockade would maybe work similarly then to the same
tumor?
I believe so. Yeah, I believe so. Thank you.
Okay. Without any further question?
Oh, last one. Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, sorry. Great talk and really brilliant work.
I'm wondering that the ARHGAP3 is also
required for other demetrilase, and did you check any other
demetrilase rather than this one?
Yeah. So ARHGAP3 important for TET2 as well.
And then TET2 has been published in-
Oh, yeah
... other groups as immunity. So yes, the TET2
definitely
will require ARHGAP3.
But in this specific axis like-
We did not check TET2.
Okay. Thank you.
It's no.
Okay, great.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you for your participation.
So I will conclude this session, and hopefully we give you the broader
concept regarding to how metabolism control cells behavior in a tumor
microenvironment. And thank you.
Okay.